gold is currently around eighteen
hundred dollars i'm sure you're jumping
up and down naked in your bedroom when
gold goes up uh
what is your uh price prediction for
gold by the end of the year
well obviously i don't have one i mean i
don't know where the price of anything
is going to be at the end of the year uh
but you know i do think that it's more
likely to be higher rather than lower
although it's possible that it could be
lower
but if it is lower it's not going to
stay lower i mean gold is ultimately
going much much higher than 1800 and
when i say ultimately i don't mean like
you know in 100 years or something like
that i mean like now i mean soon it's
gonna go up and i think the only reason
that gold is not already a lot higher
than 1800
is because
most people
still believe the fed for whatever
reason the fed still has a lot of
credibility
and so do other central banks and so
when the fed says inflation is
transitory uh they accept that when the
fed says we have the tools and we will
use them to make sure it's transitory
even if in the event that it's not
the markets believe the fed
uh so the market is not looking for
insurance it's not looking for inflation
protection uh the market is just looking
for risk the market is just buying
whatever's going up uh everybody is
optimistic they think the party will
never end
and so they don't really see the reason
to hold uh something stable like gold uh
you know something that's regarded as a
safe haven or as an insurance policy
they want to gamble they just want to
keep on uh buying the stuff that's hot
and and that includes uh a lot of
different types of stocks a lot of these
momentum stocks or meme stocks uh you
know these risk assets and it includes
you know what you guys talk about uh you
know cryptocurrencies digital assets
bitcoin ether uh you know or uh uh these
uh nfts right that's what people want
they they they just want all the stuff
that's going up and they don't even
realize that the reason it's going up is
because of all the inflation that the
fed is creating and if it ever actually
tried to fight that inflation all that
stuff would come crashing down
so but they haven't connected those dots
yet for whatever reason
is there a
piece of you that thinks okay let's say
that the fed is inflating asset prices
which i tend to agree right there
they're basically devaluing the currency
asset prices are going up
um and rather than fight the fed and say
hey they're going to change their mind
they're going to do something different
or you know i'm smarter than the fed
they're going to inflate asset prices i
want to buy the assets that are going to
go up and so just go invest in the
market rather than wait for them to make
some you know miscalculation or kind of
rip the band-aid off as you said like do
you think there's validity in that
argument of just
don't fight the fed and just go by the
assets that they're gonna pump up in
price
yeah i mean that's what i'm doing myself
but you know i am buying assets
that i think represent better long-term
values not these highly speculative
assets that i think no matter what are
eventually going to collapse right i
mean whether the fed uh you know pricks
the bubble with rate hikes or whether
the bubbles just deflate you know on
their own uh that is what happens to
bubbles i mean they never just continue
indefinitely so yeah i i don't want to
own cash so my personal portfolio
is long equities
you know i own a lot of stocks all
around the world good quality companies
that i think are trading at low
valuations that have high dividend
yields uh that are in sectors that i
think are undervalued they're in
countries uh that i think are more
stable uh and have and where the
governments are not going to be under as
much pressure to debase the currency uh
to sustain budget deficits or trade
deficits i do have a lot of
focus on resources natural resources
commodities not just gold but all sorts
of industrial commodities energy
agriculture
i have
emerging market exposure because i think
the emerging markets will outperform the
developed markets uh in an era of higher
inflation and in dollar devaluation
uh i own physical uh gold and silver so
i you know i'm fully out of
the us dollar
and i understand why other people would
have an aversion to whole dollars i
would just argue with uh their decisions
on what to buy and and and maybe
some of the things that other people
have been buying over the last you know
five years or so have done better than
what i've been buying in general but i
don't think that's going to hold up much
longer i think ultimately the portfolio
of stocks that i've put together for
myself are going to prove to be a much
better
performer in this environment
than a lot of these stocks that have
done well so far but i think will not do
well when we really start to see the
inflation take off and the dollar
really collapse
and then i also on real estate i don't
only own stocks i mean i have money
invested uh in real estate again you
know real estate is a real asset and
again all real estate is not the same uh
and so you know some real estate is
different than other real estate but it
represents a viable alternative because
when you have inflation you have to
understand that not only is it a tax
where the government takes your
purchasing power and gives it to
somebody else but it's also a giant
transfer of wealth
from creditors to debtors so the people
who have borrowed money
make wealth are transferred purchasing
power at the expense of those who have
loaned the money and if you think about
it from the government's perspective the
us government is the biggest debtor
on the planet earth i mean it's probably
the biggest debtor in the in the in the
whole universe i mean to the extent that
there there's life on other planets i'm
sure they haven't borrowed as much as
the united states government so we're
probably the biggest debtor there is in
in the universe and and as the biggest
debtor uh the us government has the most
to gain from inflation because it screws
over all of the people who loaned it
money
uh but when the government is screwing
over all of its own creditors they also
screw over all the private creditors
and so you don't want to be a creditor
you want to be a debtor and that's one
of the reasons that so many people take
on so much debt but of course the best
thing you can do with that the proceeds
from the debt is to acquire real
tangible assets whether it's real estate
whether it's stock whether it's a
private business because you buy
something real and then you end up not
having to pay for it because you borrow
the money and you buy a real asset and
then
inflation destroys the value of the
money and then you pay back the loan
with practically worthless money but you
still get a real asset whereas the
lender loans you money that had real
value and you pay him back with money
that has much less value
hey guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today
and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofa
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account sofi.com pomp and make sure
you come back and watch more of the best
business show we're going to build the
biggest business show in the world and
we need your help
[Music]